oh I'm staying steve carell said he had
worked on a sketch at second city where
he played a 40 year old virgin at a
poker game and everyone was talking
about sex and telling dirty stories and
it became very clear that he was making
his up and instantly I understood what
he was talking about and we started
writing a movie together I've always
been a big fan of seeing conversation
and with the 40 old virgin
you see there's such a master at it and
that's how we did the chest waxing
series well we wanted to do some version
of a makeover sequence so we knew that
had been done a ton of times so we were
trying to think of original scenes for
makeover montage and then he said what
if he waxed me but you did for real
whoever gets waxed
since then I realized that he had been
waxed many times of his life and was
pretending that he had never been waxed
before so we hired a woman who came in
and said I act and I Wow so we shot it
like a documentary and I said out for
our cameras and we had some basic beats
we wanted to hit we wrote out tons of
curses and we also made lists of words
that weren't real curses that sounded
like curses that's how we got the speed
screaming sequence we just put a camera
under three guys watching and there's
real reactions to the horror of them are
what makes it so fun one of the things
that happened while we were shooting was
Paul Rudd notice that the configurations
that was appearing as he kept ripping
off hair started to look like a face and
so then we encouraged her to move in
that direction and then Paul Rudd said
you look like a man O'Lantern the idea
was we just wanted to get the way you
would actually react so if you watched
your friend get whacked you probably
would just start cracking up so it
didn't seem wrong for them to laugh
during the other thing that happened
while we're shooting was Romany Malco
was sincerely freaked out including
watch any longer so we had him run out
in the middle of the theme because in
real life he wanted to run out and the
woman who waxes may not have been that
good you're supposed to put vaseline
over the nipple so you don't
accidentally rip them off and apparently
that was the step she forgot about but
we didn't know because we've never seen
anyone get waxed before so they would
never occur to me to supervise if she
was doing it properly it was clear that
she almost whacked his nipple she was
very close to removing his actual
nipples it was a big moment for me and
him we both weren't sure we knew what we
were doing we had an instinct we liked
the script we hoped we weren't crazy it
was just one of those movies that no one
saw coming that had great word of mouth
and a lot of people happen it was fun
that we all had the courage to try
something crazy and it happened to work
out